ليس جديدا انه في مواجهه مفتوحه بين ايران
واسرائيل على ساحات متعدده اهمها سوريا طب
ما هو الجديد الجديد ان هذه المواجهات
زادت بشده لانه مع تعثر مفاوضات الاتفاق
النووي ايران تريد ان هي تزيد الضغط على
الامريكان والاسرائيليين حتى تمتلك اوراق
ضغط اكبر ان لم تحلوا مشكلتي ان لم تراعي
مصالحه فسوف اجعل من منطقه الشرق الاوسط
كلها حقل الغام لكم في المقابل اسرائيل مع
تصاعد رغبه ايران في بسط نفوذها والاقتراب
من حدودها بتحاول ضرب كل المصالح
الايرانيه في سوريا في العراق واحيانا
عمليات داخل الحدود الايرانيه عشان نفهم
القصه بشكل اوضح من المهم يعني طبعا فيها
تفاصيل كثيره لكن اسهل ما تخليها ان نفهم
الاستراتيجيه الايرانيه ايران عندها
استراتيجيه
عسكريه ممكن نتحدث عنها لاحقا احنا
اتكلمنا عنها مره قبل كده وسوف اضع لكم
رابط الحلقه التي تحدثنا فيها لكن باختصار
هي استراتيجيه عسكريه بتسمى بالدفاع
المتقدم انا بنقل خطوط المواجهه مع كل
اعدائي بعيدا عني ومن اماكن اهم ساحات
الاماميه اللي بتستخدمها ايران هي دول
الشرق الاوسط والدول العربيه المختلفه
مستغله ضعف هذه الدول خصوصا بعد الغزو
الامريكي للعراق في 2003 وثورات الربيع
العربي بدايه من 2000 و 11
فيما يتعلق باسرائيل ايران عندها
استراتيجيه انه هي تقترب من اسرائيل من كل
جانب
وتطوقها تطوقها بايه تطوقها بجماعات تابعه
لها وتسلح هذه الجماعات بحيث ان هذه
الجامعات تكون قادره على استهداف اسرائيل
من مسافات قصيره الاستراتيجيه ديت باتت
معروفه والاسرائيليون بيسموها
رينج صف فاير رينج يعني دوائر النار
وهي فكرتها بسيطه جدا انه
اسرائيل عندها اسلحه متقدمه هجوميه
ودفاعيه لكن كثير من هذا التقدم في
الاسلحه الاسرائيليه سوف يفقد يعني ميزاته
اذا نجحت ايران في ان هي يكون لها حلفاء
على مسافات قصيره جدا من حدود اسرائيل
المحتله في لبنان في العراق وطبعا في
سوريا في اليمن لو امكن وطبعا من الحدود
الايرانيه نفسها ماذا يحدث الجامعات دي
هيكون عندها صواريخ
وهيكون عندها مسيرات قادره بسيارات عسكريه
هذه الصواريخ والمصيرات اذا تواجدت بكميات
كبيره وهي تملك كميات كبيره جدا تستطيع ان
تمطر اسرائيل بكم هائل جدا من الصواريخ
والمسيارات
حتى وان لم تكن متقدمه ومتطوره فان العدد
الضخم منها ومسافات الاطلاق القصيره يمكن
ان يشل دفعات الدفاعات الجويه الاسرائيليه
المتطوره وبالتالي يدمر المدن الاسرائيليه
ابرز مثال في استراتيجيه ايران وطبعا حزب
الله الى المصادر الاسرائيليه بتقول ان
عنده حوالي 150 الف صاروخ منهم عدد كبير
من الصواريخ المتطوره واللي هي يمكن ان
تستهدف
يعني يمكن ان تذهب الى اهدافها بدقه عاليه
لكن حتى وان لم تكن بدقه عاليه
الاستراتيجيه مبنيه على انه الصواريخ
قليله الدقه المسيرات الرخيصه اذا اطلقت
بكميات كبيره من مسافات اطلاق قصيره سوف
تربك الدفاعات الاسرائيليه وتشلها
الاستراتيجيه الايرانيه اللي بتسعى اليها
منذ سنوات اسرائيل طبعا تدرك هذه
الاستراتيجيه جيدا وتحاول احبطها بضرب كل
المنشات والجماعات الايرانيه الموجوده في
كل الدول المحيطه بها طبيعي انه سوريا
بحكم الجغرافيا هي هتبقى جبهه تشبه الجبهه
اللبنانيه عندها حدود مع اسرائيل
الايران بتحاول ان هي تعيد بناء او تخلق
حزب الله جديد في سوريا وتتمنى طبعا خلقه
في العراق وفي اليمن وفي غيره م طيب ده
كلام قديم ما الذي جد اللي جد بسبب تعثر
مفاوضات الاتفاق النووي انه
الاسرائيليين كثفوا من هجماتهم على
المصالح الايرانيه والقوات الايرانيه ما
فيما سبق كانت القوات الايرانيه
بتتقبل هذه الضربات الاسرائيليه وتبلع
كبريائها كتمن لنجاح استراتيجيتها التي
تحتاج الى صبر وطول نفس ان انا اتمكن من
توطين قواتي ومن بناء حزب الله جديد وانه
انا اوصل صواريخي ومصيراتي بحيث ان انا
اخلق حزب الله يصعب على اسرائيل التصفيته
لكن مع تصاعد العمليات في سوريا وفي اماكن
خارج سوريا وبل داخل الحدود الايرانيه
بشكل غير معلن او بشكل يعني لا يتم بشكل
مباشر يعني اغتيالات مش هجمات عسكريه
عمليات تخريب مش هجوم عسكري مع تصاعد كل
هذه الهجمات داخل وخارج ايران اصبح هذا
يمثل احراج للقوات الايرانيه من ناحيه قد
يفشل مشروعها في الاقتراب من الحدود
الاسرائيليه ومن ناحيه اخرى سوف تبدو
ايران دوله ضعيفه عاجزه عن الرد واذا سقطت
صوره ايران كدوله عاجزه عن الرد قد يغري
هذا اسرائيل بمزيد من الهجوم عليها وعليه
مع تصاعد الهجمات دي على سوريا ربما يضطر
الحرس الثوري او الدوله
الايرانيه الى تغيير سياساتها والرد على
اسرائيل مباشره بالمناسبه كان في دايما
سؤال قديم انه ازاي ايران لا تتردد في
الرد على هجمات الولايات لا تردد في الرد
على استنذات امريكا تسقط مقاتله امريكيه
او درون امريكي كما حدث في 2019 و2020
وفقا للمصادر الامريكيه قامت ب 29 هجوما
على المصالح الامريكيه لكنها لا تفعل نفس
الشيء داخل اسرائيل نفسها كان الرد بسيط
جدا مش الرد من ايران يعني الرد كان واضح
للمراقبين ان هي لا تريد ان تقوم بعمليه
كبيره داخل اسرائيل تؤدي الى اندلاع الحرب
فتفسد كل مخططاتها المخطط الاول انه طبعا
سوف ينهار الاتفاق النووي الايراني اللي
كانت هي بتتمنى انه ينجح الامر الثاني انه
مخططها الكبير في تطويق اسرائيل لم يكتمل
بعد وبالتالي كانت سياسه الصبر والنفس
الطويل لكن ده ربما لا تصلح سياسه في
الاسابيع والشهور المقبله اذا نجحت
اسرائيل في احراج ايران في سوريا وفي غير
سوريا ما يعني ان المواجهه والتصعيد قادم